TURKEY.
SO IT IS A COMBINATION.
SF AS WE ARE FOLLOWING THIS WITH
ON YOU ARE PANEL OF EXPERTS, I
WANT TO BEGIN WITH SOME NEW
VIDEO.
THIS IS GOING TO PLAY OUT FOR
SOME TIME.
>> WHAT WE APPEAR TO BE SEEING
IS ONE OF THE ATTACKERS RUNNING
THROUGH SOME KIND OF A DEPARTURE
OR ARRIVALS HALL.
HE FALL TO THE GROUND.
YOU SEE A GUN QUITE CLEARLY COME
OUT OF HIS HANDS.
THE PERSON RUNS AWAY.
PRESUMABLY TRYING TO GET AWAY
FROM THE ATTACKER.
AND THEN YOU SEE THE ATTACKER
LYING THERE FOR SEVERAL MOMENTS.
HE APPEARS TO POSSIBLY BE
INJURED.
AND THEN YOU SEE THE BLAST
THERE.
JUST EXTRAORDINARY.
THE ENTIRE ROOM IS JUST
CONCEALED BY SMOKE AND DUST AND
FLAMES FOR A MOMENT.
WE DON'T SHOW THE MOMENTS AFTER
THE BLAST BECAUSE IT IS SIMPLY
TOO GORY FOR OUR VIEWERS.
BUT AS YOU CAN SEE, THERE
APPEARS TO SHOW ONE OF THE
ATTACKER ON THE GROUND.